assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters  this is your brother eddie from the d  show and i have some amazing news for  you we just made a down payment and are  in contract to purchase this 35 000  square foot facility with over four  acres to make it the dean center  alhamdulillah the project includes a  masjid an athletic facility a live  studio for recording the dean show and  tawa outreach programs and as you've  known i've been looking for a no  interest owner financing and  alhamdulillah i found this church  property for 2.5 million that will do  all of it i've given a hundred thousand  dollar down payment to enter into the  contract and one million dollars will be  paid over 36 months inshallah with no  interest alhamdulillah but right now we  need 1.4 million to close on this  property brothers and sisters help us  purchase this property to build the dean  center donate right now may god almighty  allah reward all of you brothers and  sisters  [Music]